[Music]
presenter liking yeah I don't know why
this one didn't sell maybe it's just not
a good idea it's twelve adorable dogs
that just bit a toddler but yeah look
you know you can see it on the back
there you got that guy right there
then go in on this guy right here I
think you can see that blood and see a
little bit of the blood but no there it
is took a while okay here we go
here's one the 2015 just the Mondays
calendar hurts that is it incredibly -
the colors depressing look at that the
whole year oh wow you just kept Monday I
like this one I frankly am shocked it
didn't sell it's called extremely
confident men who still wet themselves
calendar look at all these guys they're
just so confident oh dear oh look at
that they're all very confident and I'll
help you here seems to be what's gonna
happen
this is one spaceship that's a lot of
urine it takes a lot of urine to get
through a space
that's Andy Richter's observation right
there hey if you love football you
should love this calendar NFL coach is
calling timeout that's the whole
calendar Wow look at that excitement
right there I think audience acts like
this is a boring one what are you guys
no I think this is really high moming no
they don't get funnier yeah
that's a nice reminder to just take a
break yeah look at this one it's the
calendar of people you think you know
until they turn around oh that's always
awkward yeah and look at this one right
here now this next one I'm it's really
embarrassing when you don't know this
person think you do and the Uncle Tony
huh okay get ready
this one's called probably their last
year
[Applause]
it's a good time he never got to take an
adventure with his best friend he died
in accident I would have been reared to
buy that in January just saying it well
here's a calendar of people who still
support Bill Cosby now there's something
suspicious these people I just told
there's something about the oh my god
this one I don't I can see why this one
did not sell it's called the racist
grandma Hall of Fame calendar calendar
these are racist grandma oh boy the
bottom yeah no would you well those are
the sneakiest one yeah oh come on in
have some cookies not I've got theories
all right finally I really like this one
Disney characters showing side boob
calendar
oh man look at all right here you got
and then
doesn't have breasts up now that's a
deer has no breasts deer has a goiter or
something said goiter all right
you